2018 a été une année noire pour le rugby
français avec trois morts trois jeunes
hommes décédés suite à des commotions
cérébrales une tragédie que redoutait ce
neurologue en 2017
je suis pas le premier à le dire mais on
journois mort soit par une commotion
cérébrale trop sévère soit par un
traumatisme abdominales ou thoraciques
parce que c'est une ville c'est d'une
extrême violence bien avant cette
funeste prédiction le monde du rugby
français s'inquiéter de l'évolution de
ce sport dès sa professionnalisation en
1995 autrefois vous aviez en première
ligne déjà un petit peu ventripotent
homme qui se traînaient d'une mêlée en
touche
maintenant vous avez des gens qui
courent comme des avions qui font le
sens 110-115 voir 125 kg qui court très
vite qu'ils se déplacent très vite ce
qui fait qu'au niveau des contacts ce ne
sont plus des des immeubles rencontre
mais ce sont des tgv qui se rencontrent
et tout simplement ça fait mal le jeu
s'intensifie les impacts sont de plus en
plus violents et les joueurs foncent
dans le tas qui t'a oublié les bases du
french flair et les tactiques
d'évitement dans les années 2000 les
joueurs s'équipe de protection tout
genre donc devant les bras dans le dos
les années passent et le jeu est de plus
en plus frontale
conséquence le nombre de plaquages
violents augmente avec parfois comme
issue une commotion cérébrale en 2010 un
neurologue alerté sur les risques des
chocs à la tête
le rugby est un très jeune sport
professionnel on n'a jamais vu un
développement musculaire aussi important
l'espace de plus de 20 ans on n'a jamais
vu un calendrier de
deux matches aussi développé en 20 ans
par contre le cerveau lui se développe
pas il n'y a pas de muscles autour du
cerveau et donc il faut bien voir qu'il
ya des impacts qui sont très très
violente
un 2012 la ffr met en place un protocole
commotion après un choc le staff médical
vérifie l'état du joueur et décide s'il
est apte ou non à repartir sur le
terrain un protocole renforcé en 2010
est pas suffisant pour cet ancien joueur
la commotion au lundi aux professionnels
dont on se rend compte parce qu'il ya la
télé mon niveau amateur il y en a bien
plus ils sont moins pris en charge
d'ailleurs que non alors certains clubs
tentent d'apprendre aux jeunes licenciés
les bases de la sécurité qui je fais un
cercle et que je ferme le cercle a dit
david recul à l'hercules la vie de recul
elle a été repérée nulle part et il
tombe déjà tout seul à prendre tôt et
répété le positionnement des mains de la
tête à saint nazaire simon sorin parle
avant toute chose de sécurité et de
règles le placage sait jamais au dessus
de la taille sinon pénalité mais le
constat est là pour la saison 2010 8
il y a 10 % de jeunes licenciés en moins
peut être à cause de cette succession
d'accidents
en revanche et c'est plutôt intéressant
il y à 13 % de filles licenciés en plus
qui elle joue un jeu plus tactique
[Musique]